i
[Música]
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu autorizó la vacuna
de moderna contra 'el hobbit' 19 la
autorización por parte de la sda llega
justo una semana después de la
farmacéutica pfiezer by un tec cuyas
primeras dosis ya se están administrando
en américa latina' a la capital mexicana
cerrará sus comercios no esenciales a
partir de hoy sábado frente al aumento
de casos de kobe 19 mientras que
colombia registró en las últimas 24
horas su cifra más alta de contagios con
cerca de 13 mil 277 casos positivos en
24 horas paralelamente anunciaba su
estrategia de vacunación
la pandemia no ha tregua en europa en
francia ya se superaron los 60 mil 300
fallecidos y el presidente de manuel
macrón sigue aislado tras dar positivo
para kobe 19 benita lee a la población
enfrentará un nuevo confinamiento con
algunas excepciones del 21 de diciembre
al 6 de enero y en austria las
autoridades anunciar un cierre de
comercios no esenciales a partir del 26
de este mes en suecia el rey afirmó que
su país fracasó en la gestión de la
pandemia
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si revelan un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en eeuu porque finalmente la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos autorizó el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna de la
farmacéutica moderna contra el kobe 19
el anuncio se dio a conocer horas antes
por el presidente de donald trump quien
se adelantó a la fd y cuando el país
supera los 17.2 millones de casos
registrados y más de 310 mil fallecidos
veamos
otra vacuna en el arsenal de eeuu el
fármaco de moderna recibió la
autorización de la fed para empezar a
distribuir sus dosis está per ley esta
autorización de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19 de modernas llega una semana
después de que autorizara mos la de
facer y bayonne tec con autorización de
la app esta vacuna adicional pronto será
distribuida a través del país por
nuestros socios federales
elpresidente donald trump celebró la
aprobación en su cuenta de twitter la
autorización se produce con la cifra más
alta de muertes en el mundo por el virus
como telón de fondo el número diario ha
superado los 2 mil 500 fallecimientos en
los últimos días oficiales
estadounidenses están tratando de
promover la inmunización con el
vicepresidente mike pence su esposa
karen y el principal funcionario
sanitario que recibieron las dosis de la
vacuna de facer y bayonne tec en un
evento televisado las autoridades
esperan que con dos vacunas autorizadas
el país pueda estar cerca de acabar con
la pandemia
entre fácil y moderna deberíamos tener
suficientes dosis este mes de diciembre
para inmunizar a los primeros 20
millones de ciudadanos en lo que
esperamos que sea un gran impulso para
dejar el virus detrás aunque tomará
muchos meses más llegar a todos los
estadounidenses
se ha probado que la vacuna de moderna
es efectiva en un 95% cerca de seis
millones de dosis están listas para ser
despachadas desde este fin de semana
contrario a la vacuna de facer y bayón
tech el fármaco de moderna no tiene que
ser almacenado en congeladores
especiales o con hielo seco lo que hace
más sencilla su distribución las
autoridades esperan que la vacuna sea
entregada primero en hospitales de áreas
rurales
con un ritmo de contagios y una
ocupación hospitalaria preocupante es la
ciudad de méxico- entrará desde hoy en
una fase de aislamiento en la que se
cierran todas las actividades no
esenciales es una medida que rige hasta
el 10 de enero y que los comerciantes
lamentan desde el gobierno central y
regional argumentan que es indispensable
adoptar estas medidas el país acumula
más de 117.000 fallecidos y 1.3 millones
de contagios veamos el informe de juán
pupiales
ciudad de méxico- y el colindante estado
de méxico unas regiones que son el hogar
de más de 20 millones de personas
reciben las fiestas navideñas bajo
aislamiento entre los motivos una
ocupación hospitalaria que supera el 75%
desde este sábado y hasta el 10 de enero
en estas zonas se cierran las
actividades no esenciales tales como los
gimnasios y los restaurantes con
atención en el local la capital mexicana
entró en el denominado semáforo rojo y
aunque desde el gremio de los
comerciantes lamentan esta decisión las
autoridades lo consideran como necesario
se han seguido aumentando los contagios
y han seguido aumentando las
hospitalizaciones que es pues en
realidad lo que más nos preocupa y
también el incremento de lamentables de
función y el ritmo al que siguen los
contagios es un ritmo preocupante
esto nos lleva a que tomemos medidas
drásticas para frenar el ritmo de
contagio ningún estado del país supera
la tasa de incidencia de kobe 19 por
cada 100.000 habitantes que tiene la
capital la cifra es de tres mil setenta
y nueve personas por encima de la media
nacional fijada en poco más de 1000
personas a nivel nacional el panorama no
es el mejor si hablamos de los muertos
por cada 100 contagios una tasa del 9%
ningún otro país del mundo vive una
situación similar según la universidad
johns hopkins la esperanza está puesta
en la vacuna y con miras a comenzar este
plan a finales de diciembre el viernes
se desarrolló un simulacro utilizando la
vacuna contra la influenza el objetivo
medir la logística y los tiempos para
cuando llegue la hora de aplicar las
inyecciones de manera masiva
colombia registró este viernes su cifra
más alta de contagios por kobe 19 24
horas con 13 mil 277 casos positivos el
país supera el millón 400 mil casos
confirmados de contagio además superó
las 40.000 muertes por la enfermedad al
tiempo el gobierno de iván duca presentó
su plan de vacunación en fases que
comenzaría en 2021 en febrero de ese año
más de 10 millones de personas recibirán
la primera dosis en un país que alcanza
los casi 50 millones de habitantes
y la asamblea nacional constituyente de
venezuela una legislatura pro
gubernamental creada en 2017 y
ampliamente criticada cesará sus
operaciones a fines de 2020 según lo
informó el presidente nicolás maduro la
institución fue designada oficialmente
para reformar la constitución pero en la
práctica termino suplantando a la
legislatura controlada por la oposición
y destituyendo también a funcionarios
públicos que desafiaban al gobierno
maduro dijo que la asamblea ya no es
necesario
este constituyente no fue convocada
jamás para hacer una nueva constitución
lo tuvimos claro aunque en un momento
dado surgió como opción por propuesta de
algunos de ustedes que esta
constituyente fue convocada para ganar
la paz para restituir la paz para
fortalecer el estado de derecho para
fortalecer el camino de resistencia
antiimperialista y ha cumplido
plenamente su misión
ha valido la pena la convocatoria al
poder popular constituyente
a medida que se acerca a la navidad las
autoridades europeas están implementando
medidas más estrictas en un intento de
detener la propagación del hobbit 19 el
continente está intentando combatir la
segunda ola del virus y muchos países
temen que los viajes durante estas
navidades se traduzcan en nuevas
infecciones
en italia de cara a las festividades
navideñas el primer ministro anunció un
confinamiento parcial
pero al 21 diciembre al 6 en ario desde
el 21 de diciembre hasta el 6 de enero
estará prohibido viajar entre regiones
para evitar el aumento de contagios todo
el territorio será declarado zona roja
antes y durante los días festivos de
jordi esteve y presstv
mientras en austria suavizarán las
restricciones durante navidad pero el
país entrará en su tercer confinamiento
desde el 26 de diciembre acompañado por
un programa masivo de pruebas
es claramente mejor visitar un lugar con
un test en lugar de cerrarlo todo y
aquellos que no quieren hacerlo no lo
hagan nadie está obligando a ir de
vacaciones oa un concierto otros caminan
de cultura hasta donde consiguen
conciudadanos
con alrededor de 8 mil decesos el
porcentaje de muertos por habitante en
suecia es mucho mayor que en los países
vecinos ahora las autoridades
recomiendan usar el tapabocas en el
transporte público
max el máximo de personas en reuniones
en restaurantes se reducirá a 4 la venta
de alcohol será prohibida después de las
8 pm en bares y restaurantes esto será a
partir del 24 de diciembre
el anuncio de las restricciones llega
después de que el rey carlos 16 criticar
a la respuesta sueca contra el virus
diciendo que el país había fallado india
superó los 10 millones de casos de
coronavirus lo que convierte en el
segundo país más infectado en el mundo
por detrás de eeuu trajes más de 25 mil
nuevos infectados y los 347 muertos
registrados en las últimas 24 horas más
de 145.000 personas han muerto en este
país consecuencia de la pandemia en
muchas partes de la nación las personas
ya no respetan y el descentramiento
social y tampoco el porte de mascarillas
de esa manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúa con nosotros feliz
día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo